[Music]
welcome
they've been favorites to win Sweden's
seventh year Vision Victory predictable
perhaps this the second time singer
Laureen has walked away a winner
welcome to the Grand final of the
Eurovision song Goddess
2023 a night of surprises from the start
[Music]
incorporated into the big opener of last
year's winner Ukraine's collage
Orchestra
short piano performance from none other
than the Princess of Wales recorded
apparently at Windsor Castle earlier
this month and setting the tone
[Music]
for a night of crowd-pleasing surprises
a thumping performance from last year's
runner-up Sam Ryder With a Little Help
from Queen drummer Roger Taylor
from 80s cars
to waterfalls
via satanic Rock
and giant hydraulic dresses
an incredible logistical undertaking
executed perfectly
and a reminder of why Ukraine simply
couldn't Host this as its entrance to
rochi took to the stage that later
emerged the group's home city was
targeted by Russian missiles
[Music]
but this was a competition and on home
turf Liverpool went wild for maymuller's
performance
not quite nil poor but a disappointing
set of scores for the UK when the
results finally came in at standing host
Liverpool had six months to make
memorable Eurovision but an act of
musical solidarity with Ukraine
the city that it could ever be hosted in
we are so glad to meet Rob here and to
have this in our city it's amazing
totally totally won me over
electric and passionate and just
incredible our winner will read
everybody
Liverpool scoring top marks for an
unforgettable night of Music Katie
Spencer Sky News in Liverpool